Hôm nay, trong phòng nào, rất nghiệp tụi tên cho biết,
nha đã cùng gấp chá tipei con sử chính giá
với làm tỷ do làm mi ý cho các bạn phải của giá trên thế giới
trong năm 2020 khi phát biểu khai mạc của họ,
phủy bán ở tắt ký thật con sử tại trudeo mắt sử vang
ngày bão với thamut, kêu của tên 1 tuo ngoài tệ
ở từ rất khẩu khí tạo điều kiện,
để ngàn lại đầu tư vào hiện đại hoàn,
các dành động nghiệp của phòng.
Mời giọc lần lực sản xuống,
và tụp đánh nhân kiểu phòng không nghe.
Hôm nay, ngàn gói biểu phát triển
hậm đáp vị thông phần sử với các đổi tác,
phục cộng đồng các khu ra được lập C-E-N
tổ chất kếp ước ăn nền tập thể C-E-T-O
và các nước châu Phi là u diền tổ thông ngàn cho biết hiện
có hơn 3 trọng của mình dự ăn hậm đáp phần sử vong nghe
là một chếc kai bọc trận biệt với mấy bụng của ra
bao gồm cánh trình đần các phủy hiện bóo
và phát triển các mộp khi tài mới,
phục bộ kỹ trường và gầu.
Nhưng các bạn có phủy,
không bu đi nói cái đổi tác,
đại buồn này vài tò mộn mở giống hận đáp vị sử vong nghe.
Không chỉ thông qua một xam bu khí,
mà còn trong bảo vệnh sử chữa.
Truyền ra không nghe và xam sử dụt theo dế phép.
Không khẳng định nghe có trọng có định truyền thông
với các nó châu Phi và xam tụi hậm đáp sử dụng hơn trong trọng trời ra tới.